foreign
has been magical but this ride is far
from over
So Adam Wainwright who has been the Ace
of the staff in 2021 appropriate to see
him on the mound and a chance to clinch
tonight A postseason bird just feels
right Adam Wainwright looking for win
number 17 as the Cardinals are looking
to make it 17 straight Yadier Molina
dealing with a right shoulder issue
nothing too serious we're told but
that's why he was a late scratch in the
lineup tonight
3-2 and a grounder hit to the right side
taken there by Tommy Edmond and the
Brewers go one two three Brandon
Woodruff hard to believe he's nine and
ten rocket has been a spectacular season
in just about every other category
except for run support that's been his
issue a 252 earned run average arnato
gets jammed Fly ball yeah it's coming in
he lays out and makes the catch
Christian yellets throwing it into fifth
gear to get that one
boy he covered a lot of ground but every
starting pitcher wants to have a record
above 500 and Woodruff the in Pursuit
they called strike three fastball right
on the inside corner Bruce drechman
Rings him up Carlson is strikeout victim
number one
Tyler O'Neill won it the previous week
and then Vader
for his efforts last week in Milwaukee
and Chicago O2 swinging to miss he
struck him out back-to-back punch outs
for Brandon Woodruff that one at 97 on
that radar gun O2 coming on Adam
Wainwright
struck him out with a curveball and the
inning is over
Woodruff strikes out three in the second
inning strands of pair onto the third in
St Louis no score
might as well be a pair
gold Schmidt lines it out to left and a
base hit
drops in front of Yelich
and Goldschmidt is one for two and the
batter will be Tyler O'Neill
daughter at first is Goldsmith one away
and O'Neill turns on it trouble it is
off the wall on a bounce Goldsmith on
his way to third they're going to wave
him home here comes a throw to the plate
and he's out so the third safe
wow what a good job of the cutoff and
relay right there it all starts with
yellets and his throw in from the
Outfield
Connors are going to take a look at it
at home plate I would imagine and pretty
close at home Goldsmith
trying to score from first base
check it out good throw by yellich
he hits irius or I should say Wong who
makes a good throw into home plate so
runnery first one away now for Luis
Urias
asuria sends one deep into left field
that is going to be a home run up into
Big Mac land
little guy with big Power
Luis Ariz with a two-run blast his 22nd
of the year and the Brewers are on the
board first here in the fourth inning
Reyes has got both of the hits for the
Brewers so far today
why a bomb
and that's fair he slaps one the other
way base hit
on his way to third goes Taylor
[Music]
so Brandon Woodruff
right off the knuckles no problem shoots
one to the opposite field
single for Woodruff
and it's Dylan Carlson had a plate
Carlson with a drive out to D price
just over the glove of Garcia St Louis
on the board Dylan Carlson Home Run
number 16.
what has this team done so many times
during this streak well they have
punched right back at Dylan Carlson not
wasting any time gets himself a fastball
in and punches back to cut the lead in
half that's what winning teams do
two to one Brewers we're in the bottom
of the fourth inning Wainwright at the
play Willie bunt again to first I bet he
does the 1-1 delivery from Woodruff to
wainwrighty squares and the bunt is down
in the first Baseline and Vader's gonna
score a perfect punt for Adam Wainwright
a great read by Harrison Vader
this is one exciting Cardinals team
we're tied at two
Goldschmidt O'Neill arnato
and Goldie greets him with a base hit
that ball is fair down into the right
field Corner Goldsmith on his way to
Second and he will stop there a lead off
double Paul Goldsmith this has been one
of the weak spots for the Brewers here
recently the bullpen third highest era
in the NL in the month of September
O'Neill base hit in the right Goldie
will be held up now he'll come around it
gets away by Garcia O'Neill racing to
Third and the Cardinals have delayed
three two miss one a sinker it's down
another great job of driving it the
other way and Garcia just snakes under
his glove
the 1-1
[Applause]
a Fly ball into Center O'Neal tagging it
third here he comes throw to the plate
he is safe and the Cardinals have a 4-2
lead the speed of Tyler O'Neill two outs
Runners head first and second
Bueno trying to gut through it now
[Music]
it's there he'll step on the bag
Wainwright is through six
and they are to Jose Rondon
rondone hits it down the left field
[Applause]
Jose
Brendon
and that hanging breaking ball by Milner
to the list of things that he has done
here recently Rondo just getting
comfortable in a roll comes off the
bench and hammers it to extend the lead
to five to two
a little more to out magic maybe swing
and a drive in the left center field
that's deep and it's gone home run
Arenado
into the Brewers bullpen
[Applause]
and it's now six two Cardinals and I
smell the coffee brewing
it's one out away from the playoffs
the 0-1 lined into Center there's better
has it
17 consecutive wins the Run of 21. it's
been historic amazing incredible and now
the Saint Louis Cardinals our post
season bound